what's up guys bang bang it is lunch
money time i am here pelina she's mad at
me i don't know why who knows
who knows what i did it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter let's just get that
out of the way
she wants to be upset so guess what
we're going to see this is what an upset
wife looks like
right here perfect don't forget that
black flies now the sponsor lunch money
lunch money is sponsored by block five i
just said that but now if i say it twice
you'll remember it so go to block five
dot com slash pomp again block five dot
com slash pump
and go get an interest bearing account
we can earn up to eight point six
percent apy
in that account and you can sign up for
their credit cards coming out swipe your
credit card get bitcoin back bang bang
go to
blockbuy.com what's up crabby
you're crabby he's a big baby
in the comments below you can say
anthony's a big
baby okay federal regulators said friday
they won't extend a coveted relief
provision granted to big
banks dashing wall street's hopes for an
extension
last spring when the economy and the
markets were in chaos the federal
reserve handed a sort of
get out of jail free card to america's
big banks it loosened leverage rules
that jp morgan bank of america and other
lenders
must abide by wow
it's actually a decision i agree with so
what does it mean
a get out of jail free card in the most
basic terms uh there were certain rules
imposed
on the banks in terms of uh leverage and
also uh capital requirements and
during the financial crisis of last year
they basically said you don't have to
adhere to those rules right now
and wall street loves it because that
means that they have to have less
capital they hold on to they can lend
out more they do all this stuff
but now it's going back to the uh the
existing rules the the non-temporary
rules
uh which is a good thing so congrats to
whoever made that decision
spax in the us have raised 87.9 billion
dollars so far in 2021
already exceeding the total issuance in
all of last year
the red hot industry is facing a
multitude of challenges in keeping up
with the meteoric rise did you just burp
was that a burp that was a hiccup
okay uh i have a wild idea
i don't know 70 of specs are nonsense
i would go like 90. yeah it might be
even more than that uh it's just a cash
grab
there are some like the highest quality
ones are legit they're real
um the ones that are merging with super
high quality uh companies
but uh i've been pitched by a lot of
people on uh on doing these
and uh i've refrained i i just think
that it uh
it's not exactly what it's meant to uh
to be
i completely agree it also hurts
founders
in a lot of situations how
uh because what ends up happening is
it's uh hyper dilutive to the foundation
the founder and the founding team got it
open c has been one of a handful of nft
marketplaces to explode in popularity in
recent weeks as collectors weighed into
the training
trading of non-fungible tokens on the
blockchain
today it announced that it raised 23
million dollars
in funding led by andreessen horowitz
with participation
from naval ravicon mark cuban alexis
ohanian
dylan field and linda chi
what do we think uh i've been using uh
open c um for uh the partnership with
ricottie the digital artist
uh and it's been a pretty great platform
if you want ricotti actually has a
auction
that's ending tonight uh at i believe 8
p.m
so it might be worth going check them
out so how is openc
different from for example nifty gateway
in short they're not they're all nft
marketplaces they have different
strategies different uh kind of bells
and whistles from a technology
standpoint different ways that they try
to partner with artists whatever so
there's there are differences but at the
end of the day the core
business is it's an nfc marketplace just
like
um nifty gateways got it
uh amazon amazon
hold on what is amazon it gets thursday
night games
nfl nearly doubles its tv deal
i think the nfl is yeah there's new
contracts that the nfl has
with i believe amazon
listen amazon just got a deal with the
nfl for all thursday night games i don't
even need to read the article
uh which means that jeff bezos and
amazon they're shelling out the cash but
shout out to my boys in indiana
that was a cough not a bird that was the
second cough not a burp
that was the third cough not burp ugh my
boy's in indianapolis let's
go who are your boys jeff bezos will you
give pat mcafee and the boys a
call we need to get them
on amazon you got the big bucks they got
the big audience it's like a match made
in heaven
give them a call pat mcafee and the crew
games on amazon will also be carried on
over the air broadcast stations in the
cities of the participating teams
also the case with games aired on espn
and nfl network
also now we'll be able to watch games on
amazon that's the point
on thursday night on thursday night
which means less time for me and you
more football time that's when you watch
football
all right
okay say corn remember what i told you
okay so there's this space junk thing
and
people are on a mission to clean up
clean up space junk
with magnets set for launch where did
you go
um all right a soyuz
suya whatever two rocket will launch 175
kilograms spacecraft
with a satellite attached into space the
spacecraft and the satellite
the debris to be cleaned up will
separate and then perform a high-stakes
game of cat and mouse over the next few
months
whoa so we're cleaning up space junk
get the trash they got the trash man up
there
with magnets sucking it all up
clean up the trash from space so when i
go up there is nice and clean and looks
shiny
like you got a new neighbor it says
lunch money time
ask lm in the comments below jmw
you get stuck in an elevator with janet
yellen for four hours
what do you talk about how to get out of
the elevator or how to get out of the
fiat system
neither what do you talk about for four
hours
i would say hey hey janet how's your day
been
and why do y'all keep creating so much
damn cash
stop it my we need a trigger warning
we need a trigger warning for the people
to turn down their their ow
i'm permanently i can't hear if i got
stuck in an elevator
you know the emergency button i keep
hitting the emergency button and being
like yo
chill out chill out no in all
seriousness look i actually think that
uh many of the people work the federal
reserve treasury et cetera they're
incredibly intelligent obviously they're
hardworking people
uh they're doing the best that they can
and frankly uh i don't envy the position
that they're in it
is a very very difficult job um i just
disagree
with uh some of the optimizations that
they make
i don't know why i keep uh coughing i
ate a couple of conducts i
ate a couple of peanuts before that
might have me
parched a little bit might explain your
peanut looking head
ain't nobody talking about that but i am
[Music]
your forehead is so big and shiny that
somebody may mistake it
well you're you're for a cruise liner
all right go see you see the violence
she just hit me
go twice go three times come on call the
police all right
moist it's day wait did you say what you
would talk about i will also pull up the
memes on twitter and show her
like yo do you see this mean so day 25 i
think today's 26 yesterday we didn't
record
he was busy not because i was busy i had
to fly somewhere what does what is
saying what do you say what is saying
i had to fly somewhere i flew in in the
morning
and i flew out at night and i may or may
not have recorded
a podcast a four-hour podcast on
somebody's podcast
it's on their podcast
it will be on the next two weeks okay
it may it may be one of my favorites
i've ever done whoa
it's not the andrew schultz that's our
name
all right so we didn't record yesterday
so does that mean today is day 27 from
probably all right what's up uh he said
i did the math
and day 90 will be episode 300 sometime
in july i would easily choose a week in
the sahara over an eskimo excursion i
could at least wear some cool robes and
wander around looking for the promised
land
also have ice water in my veins so i
wouldn't have to worry about dying of
dehydration what is he a poet
did you just say you're jesus he said
that he
would go to the sahara in a robe and
wander around looking for the promised
land
listen man you and i we may get along
pretty well
because you probably like to yell just
like i like to yell you got ice water in
your veins
and so do why everyone knows i got ice
water in the veins
question for moist
well i see above moist somebody said my
friend moved into an igloo
everything was going well until the
housewarming party
now he's homeless that's such a good
joke
that's such a good job that's a great
joke for coming back to you freedom 35
vlog
what moist what do you mean you're
making really weird sounds and i don't
appreciate them
if given a choice oh god
between
putting on
a pair of athletic shorts
khakis
or those hybrids they got now that kind
of look like athletic shorts but they're
not really cactus like
leggings no what are you going with and
why
athletic shorts khakis or something in
between
okay um gabriella update she said
she can confirm that that is her brother
who commented
he started a youtube channel a while ago
and chose that name don't ask me why
how old is her brother i think 12 i
think i need a 12 year old intern
no no he could teach me all about the
about the 12 year old
his name is his name is turquoise palm
oh yeah this guy this is a guy who oh
that's what he said last time
all right so we're going to see moist
and turquoise palm and then maybe wet
and soggy they all going to get in
what about gabriella gabriella's going
to be the judge
it's all right that's it it's friday i
got to go do nothing
and so do you so we will see ya
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends